hallo leute hier sieht eure mallmann und
bekommen zu einer neuen folge ich stelle
meinen besten freund nach mir damit eher
aus wie ich weil ich mich am
allermeisten auf dieser welt liebe und
heute ist mein ehrengast idee entstanden
war das nicht ausstehen kann wie ich
mich schminken und denkt sie könnte so
viel besser hinkriegen und ich unbedingt
sehen will in ihrer kunst also ich
glaube nur dass das eyeliner game könnte
sein
jeder hatte seine macken und hat keine
wenn ich das teil ist
ich schaue mir erstmal an damit ich
heute arbeiten denn sie werden sie
komplett neues teile das heißt augen
haare make-up klamotten mein ziel ist es
dass sie genau so aussieht wie ich glaub
ich glaube es wird sehr krass
funktionieren ja ich glaube auch hier
haben sie beide so eine knubbelnase so
litten die kurse sind nicht großen ist
klassisches gesicht bis horst glück
fressen dann fangen wir an mit den
schwierigsten teil du brauchst neue
augen ich sehe deine augen farbe ist
anders als meine meine ist sehr dunkel
deine ist sehr düster relativ dunklen
rande und aber nicht schwarz blau und
innen grün glaube ich mal weil ich ja
wenn ich zb werden die grün und wenn ich
happy denn sie gibt auch das ist folge
eines gilt
ich beende jetzt meine abend habe man ja
hier fein spiegel
es ist mein gesicht auf seinem gesicht
drauf ich gebe mich so mein gott das ist
am ernst gemacht
oh ja die sind gut was also viel licht
darauf fällt ist eine puppe so klein
dass wir so einen kleinen gelben kreis
nur mit richtig auf insider kragen mein
gott zeigt also jetzt brauchst du warst
du bist so einfach auf die hand aus
kippen und seien es noch stecken bleibt
einfach so augenfarbe jetzt das make-up
dran mitte zu einer wahren run ist
superklasse so zuerst tragen wir ein
bisschen träume auf damit die geschichte
wir sind helden
jetzt kommt das rost plogmaker ganz neu
aus dem supermarkt giorgio armani
aber dass ich sowieso ein lehrvideo sie
tragen kontaktlinsen die echte und wenn
es zum schlimmes machst du wieder
rausnehmen alter vor allem freut mich so
auf jedes mal wenn ich jemand anders
schmidt habe ich es einfach nur ich mach
das schon aggressiv wie doris auftrag
unterwegs soll ich viel dunkler sein als
ich eigentlich will ist halt auch nicht
so dass das tatsächliche punkten was
mache ich als nächstes schminke mich
dann mache ich glaub ich gleich
lidschatten nicht schminken wie mache
ich schminke mich und dann das war muss
es noch nie glaube ich in dem video bei
mir so wenig machen auch mal ein
bisschen findest du auch abfällen dich
auch so ein komisches wort bei ja jetzt
wo du sagst das richtig dämonische
dunkle augen das ist
anastasia beverley herz gehen dass man
sich jetzt auf seine augenbrauen oder
ich glaube dass mal was so werde ich am
ende dieses videos aus jetzt gefeiert
sowie noch keine augenbrauen kämen keine
augenbrauen schon vor wochen auf jetzt
nur noch meinen sind und wir werden
nichts anderes als beschäftigung übrig
als sich zu ärgern habe das ist legends
versorgen die winkel drauf machen dann
werde man glaube ich von den augen
bisschen abgelenkt sein
diese christen wir haben uns mal so
gestört weil waren es hat mir gesagt
dass man allein
jetzt müssen wieder bei meinen augen
allein kriegst was haben die augen wie
durch hab schon ein bisschen
schlupflider und wenn ich die auf- und
zumachen verschmiert das alles in die
ecken und sollte probiert macht mir spaß
wir das machen möchte
richtig nervös glaubst du denn faxen ich
der glücklichste mensch der erde
auf keinen fall
ich drehe jetzt mal den bildschirm
gucken
diese könnte den augen diesen einatmen
und auge auf das match muss ebenso umso
älter wir werden umso größer müssen
ich bin nicht ein
es ist ich habe ich einfach nur atmen
ist mein intertainment gefallen
jetzt kommen die wimpern
sie sind weltberühmt ich trage sie gerne
und kriege immer weitertreiben nur du
weißt ich hab dich stehen auch nur dir
ich dachte ja jetzt schon das alleine
drauf machen schwer ist jetzt kommen wir
an es ist noch schwer
und das war jetzt sie traten sie klipp
kannst du sagen diesen so schwer wie
meine augen für sich bleibt zu an alter
was meinst du warum ich mal so ein
schlafzimmer blick habe aber mir fällt
gerade auf wie viel make-up ich bin mit
goofy und max ist jeder tag ein glas
jetzt musst du nach oben gucken kannst
du noch umgebaut so jetzt ist es soweit
das erkennen die von lexus richtig
langeweile die richtig die sind mit den
mega werden die fenster steht mir so
extremes make up nicht so gut so das
ding es vielleicht gucken wir später
einmal ohne kontaktlinsen mache den
kontaktlinsen siehst du halt wirklich
anders aus denen klang heraus holen denn
auch lächelnd hilfe dieses zeit kontakte
machen
ich hole jetzt einen rudi innovativ also
wir und du ziehst dich auch und ich
mache mir auch motto mein gott du siehst
aus wie eine puppe jetzt auch die brille
ja ok langsam kommen wir dem näher
nun kommen wir zum großen finale den
haaren so ich würde erstmal klären so
wie er uns das ausgiebig erklärt alten
leute ihr habt keine ahnung
[Musik]
sagt hallo mein gott ich habe angst
annette ich kann diese brücke in seinem
land finden sie sieht einfach aus wie
meine haare alter gestalt besser timo
kommt die masse an
[Applaus]
[Musik]
hallo leute hier ist wieder eure mal
wanne und willkommen zu einem neuen wie
schmeckt sehen euch das video gefallen
hat dann lasst doch einen daumen nach
oben da und abonniert den kanal und
keines meiner neuen videos zu verpassen
wie konnte dieser pressekonferenz von
vanessa und vanessa wir möchten euch
eigentlich den gesang hier wird heute
endlich eine assistentin gefunden die
genau so tolle wie ich timo ist der
beste kelly ist blöd ja was wie schließt
man sowas hab keine ahnung ich bin auch
das ganze video war nun vorrangig zu
küssen um dich also wie ähnlich findet
ihr denn sehen wir uns ich muss sagen
aber jetzt erkenne ich erst du den
unterschied zwischen uns war jetzt sieht
man dass wir doch ein bisschen andere
gesichtsformen h moll auf jeden fall ich
dachte mal wir sind zwar same same but
different schon echt echt aus die rinde
look würdest du so leben wollen gar
keinen fall keine ahnung wer das aushält
und ich bin trotzdem viel weiter als du
bereit
irgendwie schon gesagt ich sehe einfach
aus wie so eine cyborg version von
vanessa wenn sie irgendwann nicht mehr
geben wird bin ich da um ihnen zur
verfügung stehen nein ich werde nie müde
wenn ich mal wie schmeckt's videos
drehen
ich backe wenn sein muss 24 7 am tag und
von mir würdet ihr so viel mehr videos
klingen als von der echten waren es ja
und dann brauchte mich ja jetzt nicht
mehr sagt vanessa g ein neues video
schneide konnte sich jetzt den weg nach
hause
alles ist auf und auszusehen überlässt
ihm außerdem kann ich dann noch zu
vanessa machen
vanessa armee ich liebe
ich liebe die einmal im jahr den mann
ist heute im jahr heute ist der
offizielle vanessa tag 29 januar und
fischl vanessa day durch einen ungemein
masons verkaufsfläche als lohn
sicherheit okay leute ich hoffe
natürlich hat das video gefallen wenn ja
dann zeigt mit dem daumen nach oben
das ist das heute kochen wir mal wieder
ein konzept aus meinem kopf zogen kunden
will alles schon tausend mal beschwert
ich habe letztens in den kommentaren
gelesen dass die leute denken du hast
die du aus deinem buch gar nicht selber
gekocht weil es so wirkt als ob sie das
erste mal kochen würde jeweils gelesen
habe weil die alles selber gekocht und
fotografiert haben
ich meine ich natürlich es ist ich kann
mich daran nicht satt sehen können und
[Musik]
die leute das war's mit dem video ich
hoffe ich dass gefallen und wir werden
jetzt nach draußen gehen und ich habe ja
denn ich bin regina